you have made a decision yeah
you come to us with a question
that is not necessary the title reads
should i come out to my wife uh yeah
come out i think this is a pretty quick
come out
of the closet
apparently what probably this is a
dilemma what now look no let me let me
be an undercover dude what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you maybe she's dying in two
months and she's terminally ill you know
what i'm saying maybe she's on her
deathbed like malcaris and he's like i'm
not gonna tell her because that's gonna
kill her sooner and i want my kids i can
understand that outside of that
tell her
tell her so you could probably wear your
rainbow run around and do all the fun
stuff relax
[Applause]
you know what i'm saying but like
yeah you should tell that might be
that's not a hard one for me
i love my wife
but i'm gay
should i come out now
okay this is really yeah it's about
people this is really yeah
why why is it a question you have made a
decision
you come to us with a question
that is not necessary in this part of
uganda we do not want your wife to see
you eating their poo-poo
we have asked bishop and hajjat what do
they think ah staggered liza
yes you are going to tell her you are
going to come out and then you are going
to get out of uganda
we do not want it it is a sickness
we have taken time to do a little
research
to find out why you are gay
we have determined that you have made a
decision we have offering a medical
essence assistance to those who have
ruptured their anus
i don't want to leave my home and this
is normal
i don't want to walk out and then i see
a sodomy everywhere i walk outside the
two man so do me no
[Music]
i'm sorry
man listen since this question is so
[ __ ] dumb i'm gonna be stupid too
how long into the relationship did you
realize you were
i gay before i got married how did you
meet your partner
we grew up in the same community
together we started off as friends then
best friends and it grew from there
is your partner supportive of everything
you do
in our viewpoints on religion yes
in terms of supporting the lgbt
community no
so religion is a big cornerstone of your
guys's relationship
we both grew up in the same religious
community so
we both grew up with the same values
and the same social guidelines so yes
do you think your wife knows you're gay
no she doesn't
well there's a main reason as to why you
went to the yes side uh i have a few
family members in the lgbtq plus
community i know all their experiences
coming out have been positive um
no no no no no no no no no no now benji
benji
i don't know what kind of ukulele using
community you come from
okay because benji sounds like somebody
who plays a ukulele same with the
mustache i don't know what it is okay
big tall dudes with mustaches love
ukuleles um
but no i know plenty of people have come
out and have absolutely horrible
experiences though maybe afterwards it
was freeing to that degree some have
lost their families other folks have
been excommunicated like listen if you
come from a hyper religious background
where they take that stuff seriously
some folks even die so
oh yeah you gotta pick and it ain't an
easy choice
so
we say you should come out not because
it's easy but because it's still the
right ethical thing to do because you're
married to somebody but you have to
understand how difficult it could be for
some people absolutely just hey wait a
minute absolutely
well i've got people in my family and
everything was positive that's your
privilege babu yeah if you don't know
people that it was not hey i know people
that were
named in the journal
dropped from their family you understand
what i'm saying
bro
what was your reasoning for marrying a
woman even though you knew you were gay
i thought that if i got married thought
it would change me the gay would go away
but gay does not go away it's made an
effort and we appreciate this but
when it comes to uganda you must go
you have failed you are sodomites
you're becoming that character
listen i don't know what i don't know if
i got distance cell service with uganda
but that channeling is crazy bro it's
great bro just like five minutes ago i
was like i don't wish to leave my home
and see sudo me everywhere
and i was like man i don't think i want
to see that
[Music]
there's something about
i even say this like i remember the
first time i heard the word doom [ __ ]
for an arab person
like the white dude was trying to find a
way to beat roxas
and instead of a black person
but he got creative
and
[Music]
when you say that [ __ ] with that
accident yeah you have to you have to
you have to warn the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the first time i heard dong kong
the first time i i almost went like this
yeah yeah yeah yeah i heard no there's
something about like sir no it's one
damn that was [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up but it's so different and
creative that is entertaining
by the way
but the era folks being like i know what
to call my friends now
that's a pretty good one think of sand
dunes and then arrows
fight rights [ __ ] you never said rice
[ __ ] never heard of that i've heard
that sounds funny
i want to be truthful
but i also don't want to hurt the people
surrounding me
i'm a very honest person i don't lie the
thing is i'm bisexual and i would have
never said anything if i ended up
falling in love with man and everything
worked out and you know i fell in love
with the woman and
i didn't want to hide anymore being your
authentic self is my principle
yeah but that's you that's a privilege
also that's that's you that's a
privilege that's what i'm saying that's
you and that's you in your position he's
not in that position so let me give you
an example i was just in london there
was a pakistani girl who had just run
away from pakistan had sat in the
embassy in london to be able to run away
from her family because they were going
to marry her off to some guy who wanted
to be a doctor then wasn't attracted to
dude she couldn't tell them the truth
she had to run away so when you talk
about living your authentic self you
have to understand in some places that's
a privilege and some family has a
privilege there's plenty of folks who
are watching right now who are probably
doing and engaging in behaviors that if
their family found out would cause all
kinds of ruptures and issues to be
authentically yourself is a privilege in
most places absolutely right and so just
understand like yes it's easy to say
that where you're from but i can tell
you you are my family or certain things
that can't be admitted absolutely so is
there an expected fallout that extends
beyond just the relationship of you and
your wife like is it more than just your
guys's relationship that's at stake
my job is tied to the church so i could
potentially lose my job i would you're
not gonna potentially lose your job you
will you are out of there yeah i'm gonna
just skip to the part where some people
apparently change their mind because i
want to see yeah let's go see that just
based on this information now
you guys can switch to the other side if
you want
he was explaining
what's at stake if he comes out
immediately because of that the more i
thought about that the more i was like
you know what he's going to be losing
literally everything because of this so
i feel like he needs to have some sort
of plan in motion first i agree with
that actually
yup i agree with that
i mean you're so tied into being a
straight man and it's so being part of
like your work life your family life and
everything that if you rip the whole
thing all at once it's kind of like um
if you've been underground for years and
you open the the entrance to the cave
you can't just look outside you're going
to go blind
there's a progressive state that you
have to do before you can open your eyes
and be outside in sunlight this is no
different if you're that deep into it
that's different that's a completely
different environment the same way i
wouldn't have told the pakistani girl
about come out to your family just like
no obviously you gotta have a plan
boo-boo so in that regards if the
question is should i come out
immediately no should i come out
absolutely those are two different
things i i
you even see this in relationships where
someone's with somebody who's like
physically hitting them
you don't tell them well like put your
foot down and divorce him no
that could lead to that person getting
murked
so you need to go through a whole bunch
of steps beforehand to make sure there's
a safety exit
route for her for the kids for him for
the kids like whatever it's got to be so
that once they get themselves out they
can't just be found right away and
attacked they have resources to protect
them they have like money and shelter
and all these things so those are things
you got to think about for sure
absolutely you need a plan yeah the
reason i said no i'm i'm bisexual same
as you it took me a couple minutes to
kind of come to terms with that so it's
like i look more at like am i safe if
you do
gone you could lose a lot of things that
you've built up on this foundation
have you at all considered reaching out
to therapy or some sort of counseling to
help you through this process
in the community i live in it's
a little bit hard to find counseling i
mean listen i don't think we need to
really watch the rest of this there's
more you want to watch
no but i'm going to tell this uh
yeah jubilee you did a good job because
at first it really sounds like a dumb
question but yeah the way you did that
was actually very clever very nice i
gotta admit i gotta say first move like
talking about it's a dumb question and
stuff like that but there's more to it
than whatever you think it is so i'm
gonna give you that it's very
interesting
to be fair to be fair the title is
should i come out to my wife
fair yes yes i still stand by that
absolutely if the question is should i
come out to my wife immediately no
because those are different things right
yes i'm about to be married after
someone i don't want to marry should i
should i run yes should i run away right
now no find a plan like i think that's
a given right we all agree on that
maybe not
maybe i'll disagree
no get away from it no i think it's very
sensible to say i want to plan out
because you might be in things [ __ ] you
got to be aware that's the thing
when i have like conversations like that
with people
i i feel like
you guys have to be aware of your
privileges
you know you have to be able no because
my motto is just to live in my truth and
my truth that's a privilege my dog yep
you have to be aware of all your
privileges
and you see
you really think that the only people
that have privileges is white man
well depending on where you live and we
did that yeah that before you know
demographic where you were born and
stuff like that that is all and that's
why it's a privilege
where you are born who you're who you're
with who's your family what's your
that's also a privilege that counters
into life there's some people there's
some black people in there that came out
that were like nah you should come out
and yeah
but
you know you have more privilege than
that person that was sitting in front of
you you have to be aware of your
privilege
in what situation you have privileges
yep
all right
anything else no all right let us know
what you guys think